[Music]
don't tell me you met with you I sent
you six short-range Heatseekers and got
a boat full of rusted parts now you will
make it right
or the next missile I send you will come
very much faster now
yeah enhanced strucker's prize pupils
candy oh sorry to hear about stocker
but then he knew what kind of world he
was helping great human life not a
growth market
you didn't know it's your first time
intimidating someone I'm afraid
not that afraid everybody is afraid of
something
cuttlefish deep-sea fish they make lots
this cannot swim to hypnotize their prey
and then I saw a documentary terrifying
so if you're going to fiddle with my
brain and make me see a jar cuttlefish
then I know you don't do business and I
know you're not in charge and I only
deal with the man in charge there is no
man in charge let's talk business
[Music]
on this rock I will build my church I
read him you know it's kind of that
great personal cost it's worth billions
now sorry you it's all under your dummy
holdings finances so weird but I always
say keep your friends rich and your
enemies rich and wait to find out which
is which stalk well Tony Stark used to
say that to me you're one of this what
Starks puppets is Hollow Men I'm look at
me do I look like Iron Man Stark
I'm sorry I'm so I'm sure that's gonna
be okay I'm sorry it's just I don't
understand don't compare me with Stark
it's a thing Stark is he's a sickness
you